Mark Zuckerberg just made a huge mistake
last month meta launched AI chat Bots to
mimic the personalities of celebrities
from Kendall Jenner to Mr Beast the
response has been unsettling to say the
least with many describing the whole
thing as creepy but it got us thinking
what if you could form an emotional bond
with an AI that might already be
happening with replica whose tagline is
an AI companion who cares you can create
an AI friend and even and get on video
calls with them the development of this
Tech could be huge what if one day you
could get married to an AI start an AI
family we might even get to the point
where you can talk to AI friends and
family who have passed allowing it to
feel like they're still with you what do
you think of AI companionship would you
try it out